Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Marx ist tot, aber haben die ihn wirklich überlebt jenseits der Zeit?
Ich glaube nein, auch wenn das Buch diese These vertritt.
Ja, denn es geht hier wirklich zur Sache. Ich will jetzt nicht direkt, wo wollen wir direkt beim Markt erstellen? Keine Ahnung, wir kommen ja im Verlauf darauf.
Wir kommen im Verlauf darauf vielleicht so viel. Hier ist die Frage, die sich ja auch Branko Milanovic gestellt hat, wenn es Menschen gibt, die durch ihr Arbeitseinkommen so immens reich werden, dass sie völlig fernab von der Mittelklasse leben, aber sie weiterhin arbeiten und auch viel arbeiten und nicht zu Rentierklasse werden, also nicht zu denen gehören, die einfach so dasitzen und dann am Ende die Miete einkassieren oder einfach nur die Dividenden einkassieren. Dann ist doch eigentlich damit der Widerspruch zwischen Kapital und Arbeit aufgelöst. Die haben ja Kapital, dass sie da noch wirklich investieren wieder in ein anderes oder vielleicht der BTF ist auch einfach ganz konservativ und trotzdem arbeiten sie so viel. Und dann sage ich ja, das war etwas, was Marx nicht voraussehen konnte. Aber wir müssen uns da auch noch mal ansehen, inwieweit trotzdem Marx noch wichtig ist, nicht um diese Klasse zu beschreiben, also nicht um zu sagen, bei denen gibt es eigentlich auch noch das klassische Ausbeutungsverhältnis, wie Marx das beschreibt. Aber das Verhältnis derer, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen, für wenig und für sehr, sehr viel Geld, muss vielleicht da noch mal mit Marx neu eingeordnet werden. Ich glaube, das kann uns gelingen.
Okay, dann steigen wir mal in dieses Buch ein. Und ich sage jetzt aber mal für mich am interessantesten. Jetzt haben wir Marx einmal aufgeworfen. Bevor wir also nachher explizit auf Marx eingehen, gehen wir mal in diesen Aspekt Kapital und Arbeit, dass Arbeit heute das Kapital ist. Denn die Zahlen, die hier genannt werden, finde ich, sind der eigentliche Einstieg ins Buch, der diesen Wandel beschreiben und sind auch einfach in absoluten Ausprägungen gesehen wirklich beeindruckend. Dieses Buch ist von 2019, wir haben eine Dramatisierung dieser Lage über sechs, jetzt schon sieben Jahre, die wir hier jetzt beschreiben. Für 2017 zum Beispiel drei einzelne Hedgefonds-Manager verdienen mehr als eine Milliarde Dollar in diesem Jahr.
Ja.
25, mehr als 25 verdienen 100 Millionen Dollar im Jahr. Das sind Menschen, die haben für dieses Geld gearbeitet, wenn man sich die Arbeitszeiten anschaut.
Also die haben einfach damit zu tun. Laut einer Umfrage verdient ein Portfolio-Manager bei einem mittelgroßen Hedgefonds durchschnittlich 2,4 Millionen Dollar. Und die durchschnittlichen Boni an der Wall Street explodieren von etwa 14.000 Dollar im Jahr 85 auf mehr als 180.000 Dollar im Jahr 2017. Ein Jahr, in dem das durchschnittliche Gesamtgehalt der 175.000 Beschäftigten in der Wertpapierbranche in New York City über 420.000 Dollar beträgt.
Du hast ja eben zu Recht noch mal darauf hingewiesen, wir sind im Jahr 2019, bekommen hier Zahlen von 2017 oder 18.
Das ist wieder eine Dekade her.
Jetzt haben wir ja erlebt durch den KI-Hype, dass die großen Konzerne einfach sagen, wir haben da einen neuen ITler, 50 Millionen Euro bekommt er jetzt, aber der ist auch der Beste. Das heißt, durch auch diese Optionen, diese Anteile zu bekommen von Unternehmen, sind ja jetzt nochmal Tausende zu Multimillionären oder dann Milliardären geworden. Und wir sind also hier schon in einer völlig absurden Phase. Und Markowitz hat ja nur solche Zahlen für uns parat auf jeder zweiten Seite.
Und wir wissen heute, die KI kann solche Investmententscheidungen ganz schön gut treffen auch. Also das ist Assistenz für die Leute, aber vielleicht auch für Leute außerhalb. Plus der neue Bürgermeister heißt Mamdani. Das wusste er 2019, also das Buch schrieb er auch noch nicht, in welche Richtung das so abtrifft. Die 14 Millionen Dollar liegt das Durchschnittsgehalt der CEOs der S&P 500. Die 500 steht für 500 Unternehmen, die sind in der Lage, dieses Durchschnittsgehalt zu zahlen.
Ich glaub bei DAX-Unternehmen sind wir bei, in Deutschland sind wir also bei 6 Millionen im Durchschnitt CEO.
Also Verwältigung mit 10 Millionen ist schon viel. Und 10% der Gesamtgewinne der S&P 1500 Unternehmen geht an die jeweils 5 bestbezahlten dieser Unternehmen.
Ja.
Es ist einfach. Also hier sind wir jenseits von allem.
Bedeutet also, andere bekommen weniger? Und das ist die Mittelklasse. Wir müssen deutlich machen, dieser Autor beschäftigt sich mit den Superreichen und der Mittelklasse. Er beschäftigt sich nicht mit den unteren 50-60%. Die interessieren ihn nicht. Das wollen wir ihm hier nicht zum Vorwurf machen. Er sieht die Mittelklasse und die Superreichen leben ein völlig getrenntes Leben. Das war vorher nicht der Fall, weil es diese Art der Reichen nicht gab. Es gab die Rentierkapitalisten, die einfach Kapital hatten und die anderen taten die Arbeit. Aber diese Hardworking-Class an der absoluten Spitze gab es vor einigen Jahrzehnten noch überhaupt nicht. Er hat hier tolle Beispiele, um uns das zu veranschaulichen, wie früher die Arbeitskultur war, zum Beispiel auch bei den Bankern. Man hat sich dann Handbücher angesehen, so Tipps für Banker oder wie man den Alltag gestaltet. Da steht dann drin, man kommt also um 10 Uhr zur Arbeit und um 15 Uhr sollte man schon mal den Schalter schließen, damit man um 15.30 Uhr nach Hause kann. Und dann wartet ja auch schon zu Hause die Ehefrau mit einem Drink. Das war die Idee vom Bankerdasein. Das heißt, man arbeitete weniger als die Industriearbeiter. Die mussten nämlich dann bis 17, die mussten oder länger sogar arbeiten, also 9 to 5 und vielleicht noch Samstagsarbeit. Aber man hat als Banker und in anderen solchen Berufen eben nicht so lange gearbeitet. Heute erfahren wir dann von Bankern, die haben eine 80-Stunden-Woche, eine 100-Stunden-Woche oder sogar eine 120-Stunden-Woche. Warum denn nicht? Was wir hier auch deutlich machen müssen, ist, wenn wir jetzt sagen, also die haben für ihr Geld gearbeitet, dann sagen wir das in Anführungszeichen, denn natürlich kann niemand so verdienen in dem Sinne, sondern wir sehen ja, hier wird umverteilt, hier hat sich eine Klasse gebildet, die genau weiß, wie sie die Gewinne auf ihre Seite zieht und nicht nach unten abgeben muss. Aber was wir hier ganz deutlich sehen müssen, was die Arbeitszeiten einbelangt, ist, dass ein fundamentaler Unterschied zu früher. Und wenn wir uns den Diskurs ansehen, zum Beispiel den gewerkschaftlichen Diskurs, war gestern noch bei der EG Metall in Sprockhöfel, dann haben wir da ja einen Diskurs darüber, könnte man irgendwie die Arbeitszeit verkürzen. Und wir haben das ja auch hier im Podcast immer wieder betont, dass das eigentlich doch sinnvoll wäre, wäre eine 32-Stunden-Woche möglich. Jedenfalls haben wir es also dort in der Industriearbeit, bei den tariflich Beschäftigten, mit Menschen zu tun, die zwischen 38 und 40 Stunden arbeiten etwa. Von der Klasse, von der wir jetzt hier reden, also diese meritokratische Klasse, arbeitet 60, 70, 80 und weit mehr Stunden. Und genau deshalb, weil sie so viel arbeitet, hat sie keinerlei Verständnis für Arbeitszeitverkürzungen, und hat sie keinerlei Verständnis, dass überhaupt jemand klagt über einen zu niedrigen Lohn, weil sie ja sagen können, seht her, wie hart ich arbeite, bei mir gibt es keine Sonntage und keine Urlaube. Deshalb habe ich es doch verdient, 30 Millionen Bonus zu bekommen.
Er schreibt nun im ewigen Kampf Kapital gegen Talent, er nennt es ja nicht mehr Arbeit, gewinnt das Talent. Ja. Und wir sehen ja auch in Deutschland, wie gerade der Bürgergelddiskurs läuft. Der läuft ja nicht über die materielle Schiene, wie wir das nachher bei Linatas noch mal hören, dass die unteren 50 Prozent nur 0,5 Prozent haben. Also es ist eh, wenn man davon noch mal die untersten 10 Prozent nimmt, nichts zu gewinnen gibt. Aber wir lassen das ganz hart über dieses, die sind faul, die gehen nicht hin, die gehen nicht mal zu einem Termin, die schaffen es einfach nicht. Darüber lassen wir das laufen. Und das ist natürlich prägend, denn die Frage, die hier im Raum steht, er kommt auf Deutschland zu sprechen, gilt das auch für uns? Und ich sage, ja, natürlich. Nur haben wir es in Deutschland immer anders hingekriegt, es zu verstecken. Die Milliardäre sieht man auf der Straße nicht, anders als in Amerika, wo man einfach weiß, wo sie wohnen und die ihre eigenen Stadtschuttel haben. Und er beschreibt ja auch, wie quasi alle Uni Absolventen der Top 5 Unis in fünf Prozent des selben Gesamtgebiets leben. Also wie sich die schon separiert haben und alle sehen hier Maralago und so. Das kennen wir ja von deutschen Milliardären nicht. Aber ich würde sagen, wir sind ja trotzdem ganz nah dran.
Die Tendenz geht ganz klar in diese Richtung, wenn es auch ökonomisch noch fundamentale Unterschiede gibt. Das können wir mit dem Gini-Koeffizienten ziemlich gut herausarbeiten. Der ist ja bei den Vermögen so, dass der je nach Schätzung bei 73 oder 76 liegt. Und um das nochmal zu sagen, also bei den Punkten, bei 0 Punkten oder einem Punkt wäre alles gleich verteilt an alle. Ja. Und bei 100 gehört einem alles. Das heißt, wenn der Gini-Koeffizient bei den Vermögen schon bei 76 ist, dann sehen wir, wie extrem ungleich dieses Land ist, was die Vermögen anbelangt. Wenn wir uns den Gini-Koeffizienten bei den Einkommen ansehen, dann ist der bei 32 oder 33 in Deutschland und das liegt nur daran, dass in Deutschland ziemlich progressiv besteuert wird. Also man bei einem Single-Einkommen, ich glaube, so ab 80.000 bei einem Grenzsteuersatz von 42 Prozent liegt, dann nachher gibt es noch die 45 Prozent ab 270.000 Euro. Es gibt ja außerdem noch den Solidaritätszuschlag. Das heißt, da gibt es schon ordentlich Progression. Die Linke hatte ja im letzten Wahlprogramm gefordert, da muss noch mehr Progression her. Kann man diskutieren. Jedenfalls durch diese starke Progression ist es anders als in den USA. Also bei uns Gini Kufizient bei 32. In den USA bei den Einkommen bei 49. Da sehen wir schon, wie extrem es ist. Und dann hat sich Markowitz nochmal angesehen. Ja, wie ist es denn eigentlich diese Ungleichheit zwischen der Mittelklasse und den Superreichen? Und dann stellt er fest, wie die Ärmeren, die spielen gar keine Rolle mehr in der Rechnung, die machen gar nicht mehr den Ausschlag, sondern diese Ungleichheit des Gini Kufizienten, diese hohe von 49, kommt vor allem durch die Kluft zwischen Mittelklasse und Superreich.
Also was wir hier sehen, wenn wir uns jetzt historisch aufschlüsseln, wir haben in den 70ern überhaupt erst diese Containerschifffahrt und Geld, das nicht mehr an Gold gebunden ist in Amerika, wodurch plötzlich unglaublich viel Geld überhaupt zur Verfügung steht für Investitionen, das sofort genutzt wird, um die Werkbank China und so weiter zu nutzen. Dadurch entsteht überhaupt erst der Bedarf an Management, anders als eben der Manager vor 1960, der wie Humann sagt einfach nur zum Akkord halt aufrief. Also es war sozusagen der Trommelschläger, aber zwar jetzt nicht inhaltlich irgendwas im Sinne von, das wäre schon gut, wenn das ein Jurist wäre, der sich richtig auskennt oder so. Also erst in den 90ern haben wir diese richtige Computerrevolution, die überhaupt erst ermöglicht, dass man Finanzkonstrukte, Managementmoden entwirft und die dann hintereinander. Also wir haben es mit einer relativ wirklich sagenhaften neuen Entwicklung zu tun, während wir immer alle denken, hey, aber im Fernsehen sind doch immer noch dieselben Superstars wie vor 30 Jahren und Berthorga macht auch in 10 Jahren noch Quizshows und so, hat sich hier einfach was komplett gedreht. Und bei den Eigentumsverhältnissen, die wir in Deutschland haben und den Bedarf, den wir jetzt eingeprügelt bekommen, das muss verteidigt werden und es geht nur über gute Bildung, wissen wir einfach, was in Deutschland droht, nämlich genau das, was hier beschrieben wird in diesem Buch. Das ist sozusagen Deutschlands Zukunft. In Amerika ist einmal durch, da wurden die Eigentümschichten jetzt einmal so verteidigt und jetzt sagt er auch, das größte Opfer der meritokratischen Klasse ist die meritokratische Klasse selber. Denn im Raum steht die Frage, ja, macht es Spaß? Und dann ist die Antwort so, nicht so richtig, macht niemandem Spaß. Aber es wird halt gemacht, weil es die Zukunft sichert, die Dynastie absichert.
Hermann nennt er Angst. Ich habe einen Bekannten, der das Kind auf eine Privatschule schicken will, ist natürlich aus einer Angst heraus. Das höre ich auch immer wieder. Also die Angst liegt vor allem darin, es wird ja manchmal so begründet, sind die öffentlichen Schulen sicher oder so. Aber ich glaube, die eigentliche Angst ist natürlich, wird das Kind, wenn es 18 ist, im globalen Wettbewerb noch mitmischen können.
Ja, und der globale Wettbewerb ist eben, das Kind muss sich in der Schule gegen 99 Prozent durchsetzen und dann in der Universität nochmal. Und deswegen kostet es einfach 10 Millionen Euro. Anders kommt man da nicht durch diesen Teufelskreis.
Markowitz schreibt, die Leistungsgesellschaft schadet auch der Elite. Eine leistungsorientierte Schulbildung erfordert, dass wohlhabende Eltern tausende von Stunden und Millionen von Dollar investieren, um ihren Kindern eine Elite-Ausbildung zu ermöglichen. Und leistungsorientierte Arbeitsplätze verlangen von Erwachsenen der Elite, dass sie mit unerbittlicher Intensität arbeiten und ihre Ausbildung rücksichtslos ausnutzen, um eine Rendite aus diesen Investitionen zu erzielen. Die Leistungsgesellschaft verführt eine ängstliche und unechte Elite zu einem gnadenlosen, lebenslangen Wettstreit, um sich durch eigene übermäßige Fleißigkeit Einkommen und Status zu sichern.
So und ich finde sehr interessant, dass er diese kleinen historischen, also von Containerschifffahrt und Globalisierung und Computern ist bei ihm nichts zu lesen. Aber er macht eben diesen großen historischen Bogenschlag und vergleicht eben Meritokratie, deswegen beschreibt er sie auch so im Vergleich zur Aristokratie und sagt, ja, das ist im Grunde fast dasselbe. Es geht um eine hierarchische Schichtung der Gesellschaft entlang von Eigentumsverhältnissen. Nur diesmal mit dem Zauberwort Leistung unterfüttert und direkt die erste Überschrift lautet Leistung ist eine Farce. Und das ist wahnsinnig interessant, weil er ist ja auch heute noch dieser Law Professor in Yale, der selber so eine Bildungskarriere hingelegt hat.
Yale, London School of Economics, Harvard und wieder Yale.
Beeindruckend, oder steht vor diesen Studenten und er weiß genau, was mit denen geschieht und er möchte im Grunde diese Zwangslage beschreiben, wohl wissen, dass man da nicht rauskommt und dass jedes historische Ereignis, Corona, Kriege, was auch immer, das nur noch mehr verfestigt. Also es ist auch so eine Zwangslage, in der er sich, also so eine intellektuelle Zwangslage, dass er da einfach einen Job macht, von dem er selber, also von dem wir jetzt einfach hören, wie er darüber denkt.
Ja, ich fand es auch so interessant, das genau jetzt zu lesen. Es wäre wirklich gut, manchmal Bücher ein paar Jahre später zu lesen. Denn das ist ja ein Vor-Corona-Buch. Und wir haben ja diese ganzen Schulschließungen gehabt, bei denen wir immer wussten, naja, für die reichen Leute ist das kein Problem. Die machen den besten Online-Unterrichter so. Ich habe ja auch mit einem Englisch-Lehrer gesprochen, also der Online-Coachings macht, der hat natürlich während des Lockdowns zu tun gehabt ohne Ende. Aber natürlich die Kinder der Elite hat er da unterrichtet. Während die anderen irgendwie vor einem Laptop mit drei Leuten saßen und nicht wussten, wie sollen sie die Hausaufgaben machen. Niemand ist da in der Familie, der sich darum kümmert. Die Schulen bleiben geschlossen, wir schützen alle, wir bleiben zu Hause, bla, bla, bla. Bedeutete das also damit, diese ohnehin schon so existente Kluft noch viel, viel weiter aufgerissen wurde.
Genau, das zum einen. Und es ist interessant, das heute zu lesen, weil wir natürlich so eine KI-Wende haben. Wir selber kennen so einen jungen Juristen, der aus Ostdeutschland heraus eine Praktika in Manhattan macht und so. Und der sagte mir schon 2014 zum Jahresende, ja, mein Jurastudium war jetzt für ein Arsch. Weil er natürlich auch GPT benutzt.
2024, meinst du.
2024, genau. Also sozusagen ist jetzt schon ein Jahr her, dass er diese Botschaft hatte. Und es gab jetzt nicht unbedingt Stimmungsaufhellung seitdem. Also diese Leute sehen ja auch, dass, sagen wir mal, wenn man jetzt so eine Minageriel-Class hat, also die fürs Eigentum managt und dann aber extrem viel Geld abgrast, die kriegen natürlich jetzt auch andere Befehle vom Eigentum. Weil da einfach Befehle vorbereitet werden mit Hilfe von KI. Genauso wie eine Belegschaft von unten jetzt auch ihre Beschlussvorlage schon mal ein bisschen anders formulieren kann. Und man nicht auf das hoheitliche, abgesegnete, der Justizia hat sich gerade die mir geschrieben, auf die wir ewig warten. So, also in Nennsicht kommen die auch wirklich unter Druck, weil das sind nun mal genau ihre Berufe, die vorher halt abgeriegelt wurden über Bildung. Und jetzt haben wir eine Pressevorführung nach der anderen, in der Brockman und Altman und so wieder zeigen, wie man jetzt im Vergleich zu den Juristen und dass man jetzt das Bar-Examen bewältigt und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist natürlich eine Lage, bei der man wieder einmal feststellen muss, der soziale Wandel, der Strukturwandel, ist so viel schneller, als wir immer glauben. Also der strukturelle Wandel und die Semantik hängen so krass nicht zusammen, dass wir hier einfach sagen, okay, es gab genau so eine Generation, die Eltern hatten gerade das Budget fertig für den Bildungsweg ihrer Kinder. 2019 wird dieses Buch geschrieben. Alle sehen noch mal, oh krass, so hart ist der Wettbewerb wirklich. Und heute, sieben Jahre später, kommen diese Kinder aus diesem 10 Millionen Bildungsweg heraus und die KI kann es besser.
Das werden wir sehen, ob das dann wirklich passiert.
Also die Abriegelung dieses Arbeitsmarktes muss neu erfunden werden.
Ja, die große Herausforderung wird für die sein, wie kann sich diese Professional Managerial Class, die super verdient, wie kann die sich über den KI halb hinaus retten. Und das stellt sich ja dann auch für ihn als politische Frage, denn wir sind also in der ersten Amtszeit von Donald Trump und so rahmt er das Buch, er kommt ganz am Ende noch mal auf Trump zu sprechen, aber sonst spielt das fast keine Rolle. Aber am Anfang ist es ganz wichtig, für ihn noch mal zu sagen, die Mittelschicht betrachtet Elite-Schulen, Universitäten und professionelle Unternehmen zunehmend als fremde Orte, die bestenfalls exzentrische Werte pflegen. Das war erst der Anfang. Wir diskutieren im Salon insgesamt zweieinhalb Stunden über das großartige Buch The Meritocracy Trap von Daniel Makovits, das bedauernswerterweise nicht ins Deutsche übersetzt wurde. Dabei müssen wir genau beobachten, was in den USA schon stattgefunden hat und was hier immer mehr stattfinden wird, dass da eine neue Elite entsteht, die sich vollkommen abdichten kann gegen die Mittelschicht und alle darunter. Dieses Buch ist 2019 erschienen, aber ich glaube, wir diskutieren es zur rechten Zeit. Außerdem gibt es im Salon dann noch unsere Empfehlungen, die besten Texte des Monats. Das alles kann man hören, wenn man den Salon der Neuen Zwanziger abonniert. Möglich ist das via Apple, Patreon und Steady. Alles Weitere unter www.neuezwanziger.de. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr auf diese Weise unseren Podcast unterstützt. Vielen Dank.